have you had to real like I got to ask
you this because there was a couple of
times like where I know A.D had like
kind of had some off camera combos with
Adam about certain [__] have you because
Adam is charged up right now he went in
on you on his IG story today he went
crazy today he went crazy and he was
like I don't know if it's the creatine
do you ever feel like you got to kind of
like have you or or would you ever like
if you think he's getting a little
playing like crossing the line a little
because you know at the end of the day
A.D pun t-rell these guys are like real
dudes you know what I'm saying and we're
and like you said outside of the content
space you're friendly with these guys
yeah
would you ever like have that like has
it gotten to the point apparently if it
hasn't yet if you haven't had the talk
but would you ever like pull out into
the side and be like
hey man like
you're playing with fire at this point
because I just saw the DMS with Heather
and I was like oh don't put her DMS
online that's not nice this is the thing
he feel like they get to say whatever
they want to say and he got to sit back
and listen well and he has been quiet
for a long time and so he just like [__]
it like like [__] want to keep
on doing it and just I mean he he was
calling them the no jumper react I saw
the the no Jefferson reaction page well
you're right I do feel like for a very
long time he kind of like was not
acknowledging it yeah so if he gets
something off his chest is like [__] it
like what are we gonna do here like I
mean like because
he feels like the people who are doing
this for Content purposes or whatever
they doing it are the people that really
walked away right and they really didn't
get fired you get what I'm saying like
it was a whole lot behind what really
went on so he like all right y'all play
victim enough but now every day like you
have said because I'm not telling my
side of the story now he's telling his
side story he's going wild he's going
down he's going up he's going on what
you call it hang out with your hangout
that's what he's doing right now I was
gonna say for you like I think like
there's a lot of misconceptions about
Adam but I think one of the main things
that people will talk about is how like
for whatever reason he's extremely
infatuated with gang culture yeah and if
you look at the previous regime of
co-host and the new regime of co-host
his scripts yeah yeah he [__] with the
Crips I guess the narrative about Adam
is like hey he's infatuated with you
know black violence gang culture this
that and the fourth but then like you'll
realize like Adam I think it's just
really like a very curious dude who's
just like a true content creator so like
you know these are the people he's
around and what like I don't feel like
he like purposely sought brick baby out
because you were a [__]
who you say what no ad I'm talking about
Adam oh he's about the misperceptions of
Adam oh yeah no no me and me and me and
Adam been cool since like
2015. because I think people are like yo
okay 80 and t-rell left and he just went
and got more Crips but me and dub like
dub is like an honorary crib he all he
does is hang with the Chris
I mean he went to Adam's wedding yeah so
uh
uh he's always been cool with dub and
the people that dub break around and the
fact that me and Doug have like a great
relationship that's how we even got
closer than what we you know I'm saying
when we first met whatever it was so
uh when I came home I came I did the
interview I could pop back up I did an
interview then I started like being on
YouTube but I didn't really understand
so I started reaching out like hey how
dude he's like you should come on yeah
like and we'd start going into
hey I feel like I'm ready to I mean hop
on camera like [__] well you guys
already having those conversations prior
to 80 leaving yeah we was already I was
already down there
he was there like multiple times when I
was coming up there like for like news
and different little [__] like that so I
didn't even see because I don't go home
like this [__] tires you out sometimes
to where I don't go home and watch the
[__] we were doing yeah
and then I go back and and go watch it
you get what I'm saying so even if like
I just seen 80 Adam so when I was seeing
the the headlines and all that [__] like
somebody leaving or whatever I'm like
yeah
I don't really want to get into the [__]
that's going on right you know what I
mean the mess because it's like gossip
you know what I'm saying because if it's
not coming to my phone directly I'm not
really so I'm like I was paying no
attention to it then when they start
being everywhere I'm like oh wait that
ain't no click bait type [__] you get
what I'm saying like if that's how slow
I am when I'm first coming in I'm like I
don't know I'm thinking they trying to
get the numbers up or something so now
I'm seeing Oh it's less than this that
and I'm like oh
is going down in this [__] like
I'm texting Gina Gina trying to hold it
stand their ground and then she go that
was a wild that was a extremely wild
um
extremely Wild
couple of days because I
got uh
hit up by Adam to come and fill in for
Lush or fill in for whoever
not knowing that he had just fired Lush
and
and so I called ad and I know Adam
called me and told me what happened with
Lesh and he was like I need somebody
tomorrow to be on the show so I called
A.D and I was like yo
uh what's the deal you know like
he's like yo do it there tomorrow he's
like he's like I think he's like I'm
about to leave oh [__] yeah cause I I
didn't talk to A.D about it but I
already know what his response was going
to be to me because yeah we already was
there so right and then what do I I
don't have a job y'all leaving with it
like I'm just getting you everybody's
like oh you stayed or you was with no
jumper after that so what who was
offering me a spot where they at where
who did I leave from right where I
stayed at yeah you were already I'm not
a part of that crew that makes sense I
was gonna say uh recently you guys
interviewed the gay [__] guy
which uh was extremely interesting
to say the least I just like sharp just
in the corner just like what the [__]
happening not sharply hey print back
said some [__] where he was like you
know DP would he educated the dude who
what a DP was he's like not getting your
whole [__] blown out by a bunch of
n-words
but I was gonna say like when you do an
interview like that do you hear about
that from like your like big homies like
yo what are you doing yeah they but no
all right so the big Hobbies was mad but
they thought I was stamping
homie yeah the whole time I'm like
letting him get his [__] off and telling
him like
nah we ain't going for that well he also
clearly is in a [__] yeah he's remover
or whatever he's doing this and like how
are you a gang member you don't know
what a DP is that's what I'm saying it
is it's like you guys were educating him
yeah that's what I'm telling I'm like
the lack of knowledge like bro you don't
know what that is that you said that you
from so that's why I told him like all
throughout the interview then at the end
I really thought I'm like
they gotta watch it man they gotta watch
it because the whole interview ain't now
he keep on serving ClickBank I mean uh
clip after clip he does you know what he
does but once the whole interview drops
the whole interview Drive you'll see
what's going on I'm definitely not
stamping no gay [__] and he's from over
we don't really like yeah I mean like
I'm not gonna keep on saying that
because but at the same time I can't
even in politics why I can't eat politic
on him I can't give him a DP beat him up
or nothing because he's not just a crazy
movie that goes yeah I mean actually
they got a deal I just saw the clip and
it was so funny uh shout out to [__]
Mack who's one of the most widely
entertained human beings that's ever
walked the face of this Earth uh